bonjour et bienvenue pour ce premier set
huit week-ends de l'année 2016 votre
émission dédiée aux loisirs et vos
sorties
au sommaire jusqu'au 16 janvier le
centre social du pont du retour de
guyancourt propose plusieurs
manifestations autour du poète et homme
politique aimé césaire l'association
quercynoise metas au sein des trois
groupes date listera cas se produire sur
la scène de la tour pour une soirée
concert et nous découvrirons le travail
de jacques de givry photographe yves
binois passionnés de paysages et
patrimoine
c'est le territoire de l'ancien grand
parc de chasse royale dans lequel
s'interroge saint quentin en yvelines
qui l'inspirent depuis le 4 janvier
l'espace yves montand du centre du coup
dur ou soir à guyancourt et itinéraire
poétique fondane hommage à aimé césaire
auteur poète et homme politique
martiniquais
plusieurs manifestations sont proposées
autour du pot être notamment avec une
exposition et des ateliers d'écriture
jamais le brescia le responsable du
centre social et jacques fournier le
directeur d'itinéraires poétique
viennent nous parler de la programmation
bonjour à tous les deux jours
ajoutons d'abord vers vous monsieur
jamais le brave pourquoi accueillir une
telle manifestation
alors tout d'abord parce que au niveau
du centre social on a vocation à
développer des actions d'ouverture
culturelle et
on est en rencontrer les itinérants
politique comme partenaire sur le
territoire il me semblait intéressant et
très important aussi symboliquement de
proposer cette exposition sur sûr aimé
césaire aimé césaire c'est un grand
homme politique
chaque fournée est ce que vous pourriez
vous faire un petit portrait est
difficile de tirer un portrait d'un tel
homme qui a quand même traversé tout le
xxème siècle de sa naissance en 1913
jusqu'à son décès en 2008 dans ce qu'on
peut dire c'est que ça a été un des
grand grand grand c'est toujours un des
grands monsieurs la poésie de langue
française doublée d'un homme politique
engagé très engagé
sur sur la défense des opprimés sur la
défense de du fait d'être noir dans un
monde de blancs dominée par la race
blanche comme on disait à l'époque lui
dans ce pc de cette terre de france que
sont les antilles a défendu l'existence
de l'homme noir de ses droits et de ses
devoirs aussi et en l'universalisme tout
le travail qu'il a fait au niveau de la
avec ses compagnons de route de ce qu'on
a appelé le mouvement la négritude avec
léopold sédar senghor le sénégalais et
léon gontran damas le grand oublié
guyanais et d'autres encore aux états
unis et en amérique
tout ce travail a été très important et
il en reste énormément de marques dans
notre dans notre paysage politique dans
notre paysage littéraire et c'est ça qui
est très intéressant c'est que cette
figure qui est devenu une sorte de
figure tutélaire de grands sages sur la
fin de sa vie que tout le monde allait
voir tous les hommes politiques à les
voir il est bien quand même rigoler dans
son dans son bureau de la mairie de
fort-de-france de recevoir et en même
temps c'est devenu faire plaisir parce
que c'est une souvent reconnaît les
poètes quand ils sont morts lui il a eu
cette chance d'être reconnu de son
vivant
et ça c'est une très très bonne chose et
toute cette manifestation jusqu'au 16
janvier ce que vous voulez mettre en
avant c'est quoi c'était ses qualités
littéraires
c'est un poète reconnu vous l'avez dit
son combat politique tout est lié
tout est lié tout est venue de l'accueil
qui aurait dû se faire dans les murs de
la maison de la poésie qui a été fermée
de l'accueil par la ferme de bel ébat et
là les nouveaux itinéraires politique du
spectacle de jeu le coup sous le cahier
d'un retour au pays natal que j'ai eu
l'occasion de voir il ya un an et demi
avignon et qui est un très beau travail
qui donne une véritable accessibilité un
texte qui n'est pas si facile que ça qui
est un texte fondateur et donc à partir
de là à partir du moment où ce spectacle
a été déplacé au l'espace yves montand
jamais nous a accueillis tout de suite
je suis allé le voir les deux en écoute
on va on va bosser ensemble on va
essayer de développer des choses autour
et ça on aime faire ça aux est une
erreur politique c'est à dire être
porteur d'un projet qui rassemble autour
d'une dinde un pôle central ce pôle
central c'est le spectacle autour il y à
cette exposition
il y a cette conférence lecture et cet
atelier d'écriture et tous
jamais les son équipe développe aussi
avec les habitants et c'est ça aussi qui
est très intéressant c'est cette
interaction entre notre expertise nous
culturel littéraire poétique et l'
expertise territoriales sur le pont du
ruisseau noir de l'équipe de gmail ça
c'est le fond du rotois à sa place
importante au tour en fait l'exposition
7 en collaboration avec le pont du
rotois tout à fait l'exposition réalité
est un outil pour nous en fait de
développer davantage d'accès de culture
dans ce type d'équipement ça permet
aussi d'élargir le concept qui était une
matrice centrale gérée dans le dans
l'oeuvre d'aimé césaire qui est la
négritude dans un concept d'humanisme et
de vivre ensemble on ne sait très bien
que
aujourd'hui il est impératif de
travailler dans ce sens là et c'est dans
ce cadre qu'on a essayé d'élargir la
programmation au niveau du centre social
et c'est dans ce cadre qu'on organise
notamment demain soir une soirée
interculturelle du vivre ensemble
cette question du vivre ensemble c'est
quoi c'est discuter ensemble c'est
comprendre les différences de chacun
c'est respecter l'autre avec sa
diversité
et c'est dans ce cadre là qu'on a essayé
de mobiliser et qu'on a mobilisé neuf
associations issus issu d'une diversité
culturelle dans l'objectif en fait de
faire justement cette promotion des de
la richesse culturelle qu'on a sur notre
territoire
elle tourne les uns des autres apprendre
les uns des autres et surtout respecter
aussi apprendre les uns des autres pour
permettre justement de développer
davantage de respect un moment donné sur
avec qui sur d'autres avec d'autres
populations et d'autres pratiques
culturelles
ce sont les thèmes forts les thèmes et
mais finalement de aimé césaire oui et
que vous allez développer dans l'atelier
d'écriture
oui ils vont être exposées dans la
conférence de bernard ascal ce vendredi
donc à 19 heures bernard ascal qui s'est
emparé au site c'est cette parole d'aimé
césaire puisqu'il est chanteur de poètes
et donc il a adapté intégralement le
cahier d'un retour au pays natal avec
aimé césaire aimé césaire était au
courant puisqu'il a le disque est sorti
je crois trois semaines après le décès
d'aimé césaire en 2008 et oui lors de
l'atelier
le but c'est de pendant ces deux heures
samedi après midi de s'emparer de
thématiques fortes chez chez aimé
césaire l'humanisme le rapport à l'autre
la défense de l'opprimé la diversité moi
je suis différent de toi mais moi je
t'apporte des choses que toi tu ne
possède pas et c'est cela qu'on va
essayer de et et moi différent de toi je
m'enrichis de toi et c'est ça qu'on va
essayer dans ces deux heures on s'est
donné d'aborder à travers des formes
très courtes très simple qui seront
visibles je pense après au niveau du
centre
mon temps c'est à dire on les affichera
il faut les montrer alors faut les faire
entendre sont valorisés et je trouve
intéressant que voilà on puisse
s'appuyer sur ce set cet écrivain
magnifique aimé césaire difficile par
moments mais fulgurant avec dédé des
accès magnifique dans dans sa
littérature autant dans le théâtre
d'ailleurs qu'on connaît trop peu une
tempête le les chiens se taisaient
houleux la tragédie du roi christophe
dont quand il le but aussi est de faire
découvrir comment un homme a pu
s'emparer de cette thématique là de par
sa propre situation d'étudiants de jeune
étudiant à la sorbonne dans les années
30 comme ans ce jeune homme venu de
venus des antilles c'est dans les années
juste avant que le monde explose à poser
tout ce qui va devenir son engagement
jusque jusque sa mort jusque 2008
j'aimerais déjà ces thématiques que
développe aimé césaire vous en tant que
responsable du centre social vous les
voyez vous les entendez de la part de
personnes que vous rencontrez je les
entends je les observe surtout il faut
savoir que actuellement on a des ford et
je donne un exemple des cours de
formation socio linguistique on a des
nouveaux arrivants qui veulent essayer
justement d'apprendre des maîtriser
cette langue française
on sait très bien que aimé césaire est
un maître de la langue française est
symboliquement c'est important aussi
pour nous de de faire la promotion de
cette langue et de et peut-être de se
pencher un petit peu sur la manière dont
aimé césaire la maîtriser voilà alors
c'est sûr un genre littéraire qui est
très ancien qui est la poésie
mais on va essayer de sensibiliser nos
public justement à cette pratique là et
notamment dans le cadre des ateliers
d'écriture qu'on pourra voir avec avec
jacques fournier justement vous parlez
du public
c'est pour qui les jeunes les moins
jeunes les adultes alors au regard de
l'ensemble notre programme c'est
vraiment pour un public
intergénérationnel c'est à dire que sur
cette exposition par exemple à 17 heures
je prévois de faire une visite guidée de
cette exposition direction d'un public
collégiens pour les sensibiliser à ce à
ce poète il ya d une soirée
interculturelle où la ces pour un public
intergénérationnel on sera plus sur
l'aspect gérer ludique festif il ya
également d'autres d'autres spectacles
on avait un compte le compte des neuf
continent qui a été proposé par prague
gay para et en partenariat avec la ferme
des bel ébat qui était également à
destination d'un public parents enfants
donc on s'adresse vraiment un public
intergénérationnel
vous parlez de l'exposition c'est celle
qui couvre toute la manifestation elle a
été pensée comme ans et qu est-ce qu on
peut y voir cette exposition elle existe
depuis longtemps
ce sont des sites une exposition que la
maison de la poésie avait acquise avec
d'autres expositions monographiques sur
d'autres poètes hampate ba
max jacob andré breton et cetera que
l'on a fait monter sur carton sur carton
plume est qui et qui a été beaucoup
prêté aux prés de deux collèges de
lycées de bibliothèques et j'ai réalisé
un panneau qui synthétise les derniers
moments de d'aimé césaire son décès
l'hommage national rendu au panthéon et
son sont ceux comment dire ça
ce sont le lien qui a été créée par
l'unesco dans un projet qui s'appelle
universel réconcilié auprès des poète
rabindranath tagore et
pablo neruda voilà en 2011 est donc un
projet sur lequel dans lequel on
s'inscrit complètement aussi c'est à
dire valoriser à la fois cette écriture
là mais aussi les valeurs de ces
écritures la voie là est dépassé le
simple non littérale voilà aller au-delà
de ce à travers différentes
manifestations qui lie les trois poètes
ou qui parlent de chacun des trois de
ces trois poètes essentiel du 20e siècle
a pris deux prix nobel aimé césaire donc
je regrette tout à fait que les mets
saisir n'ai pas reçu de prix nobel il
aurait mérité
voilà et pour nous pour terminer aussi
sur ce lien aussi il est essentiel que
nous puissions liés j'ai en parlé ce qui
va se passer lundi soir au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
cette manifestation qui nous avons dû
annuler le 15 novembre pour fait
d'attentats et que nous avons reporté
dans l'enchaînement dans la continuité
de cet hommage à aimé césaire
ça aura lieu au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à 19h30 nous
allons accueillir les écrivains
journalistes que nous aurions dû
accueillir le 15 novembre à voisins
c'est à 19h30 c'est ouvert à tout le
monde c'est dans la petite salle dans le
petit théâtre il ya de la place faut pas
hésiter à venir faut remplir cette salle
pour dire non non à la connerie humaine
non à la bêtise à l'obscurantisme quel
qu'il soit celui que combattait
complètement aimé césaire et c'est
d'autres poètes encore maintenant
continuer à combattre ceux qui sont
enfermés ceux qui sont condamnés à mort
comme achraf fayyad en arabie saoudite
c'est à dire que nous c'est un véritable
combat la poésie est un combat et donc
l'humanisme pour le retrouver
ça commence dès ce soir vendredi 8
janvier avec une conférence lecture qui
est proposée par bernard ascal que poète
peintre compositeur et chanteur
autre rendez vous on disait le samedi 9
janvier les thèmes chers convient de
développer à 2 aimé césaire seront
travaillés donc lors d'un atelier
d'écriture et les jeudi 14 et vendredi
15 janvier c'est l'acteur jouait le
kosovo nous le dj qui prête sa voix aux
premiers textes d'aimé césaire cahier
d'un retour au pays natal
c'est un menteur 30 à la ferme devait
les blancs à l'espace montant à l'espace
insultant elle est imprécise dessin
québec merci à tous les deux
vous venez pour ceux qui veulent
réellement vivre une action c'est-à-dire
d'être dans concret du vivre ensemble je
vous invite à participer à notre soirée
interculturelle prévu j'y suis le
l'atelier l'écriture à partir de 18h à
l'espace yves montand merci tous les
deux détenus par et d'aimé césaire on
change de sujet pour la suite on passe à
l'artiste en résidence de la commanderie
des templiers florence rochelle
questionne la manière dont les
technologies peuvent transformer le
temps et l'espace
son exposition manifester contre la
pesanteur est à découvrir jusqu'au 20
mars
sephora l'allemagne et william elle nous
en donne un avant-goût la destruction
peut être fascinante florante rochelle
plasticien réalisateur et vidéaste a
choisi pour sa série intérieur de
construire par le démantèlement
artiste associé de la commanderie des
templiers dans le cadre de la saison
arts numériques
il propose son exposition manifester
contre la pesanteur jusqu'au 20 mars
ce qui était intéressant avec le travail
dépendantes rochelle c'est que il les
plasticiens mais pas que il est aussi
auteur metteur en scène et que du coup à
la commanderie
exposé son travail arts visuels de vidéo
mais on explorera pouvoir travailler sur
le reste de la saison avec des
performances avec de l'écriture sur un
ensemble de 20 vidéos 18 ont été
réalisés in situ lors de sa résidence de
création à la commanderie en septembre
dernier
au travers de ces vidéos il interroge
notre perception de la réalité
en proposant une exploration sensible du
rapport à l'espace et à la technologie
il ya un sens profond à ce que fait
florent sur l'espace sur le rapport des
choses entre elles sur le corps sur le
rapport entre le corps et les choses
l'espace réel l'espace virtuel tous à
ces deux questions qu'il a et qui sont
proposés de façon est très forte mais on
n'est pas obligés de les comprendre
on n'est pas obligé de s'y intéresser
parce qu'il a aussi un univers visuel
extrêmement fort moi je trouve
personnellement très onirique et donc ce
qui est important c'est de se laisser
porter dans le cadre de cette exposition
une installation artistique la percée
pensé par l'artiste lors de son premier
passage et la commanderie a été
spécifiquement créée pour le lieu
on poursuit cette 7,8 ce week-end avec
notre nouvel invité le rock est à
l'honneur ce week-end à voisins le
bretonneux avec un concert proposé par
l'association met ta sauce pierre michel
bouchard planchon bonjour bonjour vous
êtes corning coordinateur de
l'association alors samedi 9 janvier
c'est la soirée mars et vénus pourquoi
la non déjà fait pas ce qu'on avait
envie de mettre à l'honneur la
masculinité et la féminité
donc c'est une soirée tournait autour du
rock et c'était aussi un petit à l'envi
voilà de dire que la musique n'a pas de
sexe et montrait que les fils à faire
aussi du rock donc voilà on a un groupe
composé de garçons et de groupe
essentiellement féminin allez je vais
commencer avec les dames
oui parce que c'est finalement elle
convoie le moins dans le monde du rock
vous recevez le groupe ausy n'est
l'artiste mulhouse laisse j'espère que
je prononce bien c'est tout bon est ce
que vous nous donner quelques
indications sur l qu'est ce qu'elles
font d'où elles viennent
oui bah on a osé ligne du cou couvrira
la soirée donc c'est un trio féminin
voilà qui nous plonge dans un univers
totalement rock à la fois intimes brut
et fantaisiste
voilà pour moi un univers à elle qui
voit là elles font vraiment du rock du
coup ça envoie et s'écoulent et milou
laisse du coup c'est vraiment un peu
différent elle est rock'n'roll gérés
peuvent forcément dans la musique elle
même mais la personnalité celani
chanteuse vraiment voilà qu'à des textes
vous dites un peu moins rock'n'roll elle
est plus accessible à un public qu'il
connaît très mal rock ou c'est quoi ça
joue sur quoi oui de toute façon la
soirée elle est quand même large et
s'adresse à tout public
après on va dire que c'est plus une
ambiance intime poser c'est vraiment des
chansons voilà c'est une chanteuse on va
dire à voix
elle se définit comme une sorte de nokia
fait ce que vous savez un peu pourquoi
wima parce que je pense ça fait partie
ces influences voilà des artistes
françaises comme ça de renommée que marc
et la variété du coup ça fait partie ces
influences voilà savoie vient
essentiellement du blues elles seront
bondi douala de toutes ces influences
mais je vous propose d'écouter un
extrait pour se rendre compte du travail
de molex partout
le temps s'enfuit sommes-nous
l'aigle a rendu notre v
donnez-moi voir
j'ai plus d'amis
pour y croire
bien longtemps c'est très doux en fait
c'est apaisant presque tout à fait voilà
un répertoire ce qu'on attend - deroff
finalement passe quand on connaît moins
que ça peut être du goût et cette très
belle relatif ce que j'ai mis la mêlée
les on sent que le rock ouvre surtout
bien sûr le rock c'est très large et
c'est ouvert ses vaccins une esthétique
qui regroupe beaucoup de choses donc là
quand même varié ça qu'on aurait
tendance à dire que c'est quelque chose
qui fait du bruit assez plutôt agressif
mais moi je sais pas y adhérer aux
français comme téléphone jean jacques
goldman je trouve pas ça si agressif que
ça il en faut c'est une question de goût
après tout à fait sûr tout à fait vous
recevez aussi un groupe d'hommes bah oui
plié avant d'en parler c'est qu'andy
boulevard et je vous propose de nouveaux
d'écouter un extrait
lui non event will be blood c'est triste
au fond et je pleure comme un sol
voir
sa mort
je viens
du boulevard c'est plus énergique un peu
plus énergiques en effet là on est sur
un groupe qui tire ses influences
vraiment dû dire du garage un peu du
blues vraiment vintage années 60 à la
fois de la nouvelle scène française
donc on a vraiment trois groupes aussi
on met à l'honneur les textes écrits en
français donc c'est l'occasion aussi
c'est très important de défendre cette
belle langue qui est la nôtre et ce sont
des groupes locaux tout à fait tout à
fait donc on a deux groupes d'ailleurs
qu'on accompagne dans notre dispositif
studio session donc c'est un dispositif
qu'on a mis en place depuis maintenant
en 2011 qui était sous forme de compiler
depuis là cette année
depuis 2015 si on est en 2016 maintenant
c'est vrai on a intégré de la vidéo
voilà donc c'est pendant un an
n'accompagne les groupes dans leur
projet de soutien puis ça leur permet
d'avoir une expérience d'enregistrement
à dans des studios de façon
professionnelle parce que votre assiette
votre association ce n'est pas que du
concert c'est de l'accompagnement c'est
de l'aide c'est de faire découvrir des
groupes
tout à fait c'est exactement ça voilà on
a aussi une partie de suivre une
répétition d'enregistrement votre un
régisseur qui est de la pour les
musiciens les accompagner au quotidien
sur s'ils ont des questions et on a dit
positif dispositif par mois +
particulier voilà qui les aident à se
développer va les faire connaître en
tout cas dans le bassin notamment de
saint quentin mais aussi évinois merci
pierre michel planche vous nous
présenter votre association et cette
soirée si la soirée mars et vénus vous
intéresse c'est donc le samedi 9 janvier
à la salle de la tour de
voisins-le-bretonneux les billets sont
disponibles sur le site internet de
l'association
avant de retrouver nos deux prochains
invités qui nous parleront photographies
nous prenons la direction du palais du
canal cette semaine laurent gare à vous
présente un ouvrage dédié à charles
aznavour
le chanteur mais aussi l'acteur qui a
joué dans plus de 80 films nous présente
aznavour ma vie mes chansons mais film
donc est le dernier livre sorti sur
charles aznavour et avec charles
aznavour surtout donc
là on va suivre toute sa vie son oeuvre
mais égrainé surtout d'entretiens qu'il
a pu avoir avec le journaliste donc on
va découvrir finalement qu' il a eu un
parcours vraiment atypique et très très
prolifique que ce soit au niveau
cinématographique comme au niveau de la
chanson et donc voilà on égrène toute sa
vie à travers des interviews qui
viennent entrecouper qui viennent en
fait et ayez un peu les photos sont
c'est tout un beau livre qui parcourt
donc comme je voulais 10 sa vie mais
voilà il ya beaucoup d' affiches de
films il ya beaucoup d' affiches de
concerts beaucoup de photographies de
personnes qu'il a pu rencontrer et qui
finalement ont fait aussi à lui sa
carrière en passant par edith piaf par
jean cocteau et après toute sa
filmographie qui est quand même
foisonnante et que malgré donc cette
implication dans le cinéma il a eu aussi
et enfin il a continué de chanter
donc voilà c'est de vie en parallèle ses
deux carrières qu'il a réussi à mener en
parallèle
donc voilà il revient sur tout ça sur
cette vie commence à ces mises en place
et comment il a réussi à perdurer des
années 50 jusqu'à aujourd'hui
autant l'une soit 7,8 week-end avec la
découverte du travail de jacques de
givry photographe yves binois il est
accompagné de claude chose le président
de l'union régionale photographique
bonjour à tous les deux jours et demi et
je me tourne vers quelque chose en
premier pourquoi avoir choisi jacques de
givrer cette semaine alors d'écouter
toute façon parce que je connais le
travail de jacques du jury depuis longue
date jacques de givry est un monsieur
qui a travaillé énormément sa
photographie sur le parc de le grand
parc de versailles ce qu'on appelle le
parc de chasse donc jacques nous
expliquera précisément ce en quoi ça
consiste
et qui englobe les communes une grande
partie des communes de saint quentin en
yvelines donc voilà pourquoi j'ai choisi
jacques et son travail photographique
est absolument extraordinaire être été
un travail de documentaires un travail
de chasseurs de d'image de chasseurs
d'image sur le grand pas et avec de plus
il est aussi président des amis de
l'association de versailles grand parc
qui est justement cherche à reconstruire
à donner des perspectives que le nôtre
avait dessiné en son temps c'est menée
sur le pain mais je pense que jacques
sera plus à même de nous expliquer son
travail
jacques de givre est ce qui vous plaît
on va le voir à l'image vos photos vous
être présenté ce qui vous plaît surtout
c'est les paysages le patrimoine et sud
versailles d'où vous vient cette passion
cette envie de photographier leur
environnement c'est une passion qui
remonte à mal d'années mais s'est pas
montrée initialement taille initiale
c'était sur belle île en mer par exemple
où ça a été sur saint-émilion ou
varangéville des petits villages
pittoresques français et puis habitants
sur le plateau de saclay j'habite en
fait aux loges en josas
j'ai été amené à travailler sur une
région proche où je pouvais faire un
petit saut dès que je voyais que la
météo était bonne et je filais sur le
parc de versailles par exemple pour
faire des photos dans le brouillard avec
la neige etc
et puis de fil en aiguille j'ai été
amenée grâce à la photographie
d'ailleurs à m'intéresser au patrimoine
et un petit peu à sa défense à sa
sauvegarde
donc ils se retrouvent je me retrouve
actuellement en tant que président des
amis du grand parc de versailles est une
association qui rayonne comme ça autour
de versailles sur cet ancien grand parc
de chasse on en parle du grand parc à ce
que vous pouvez nous le définir parce
que l'absolu oui alors le grand père de
chasse et 8600 hector paris tiendrait
dans ce territoire et il y avait un mur
de 43 km autour de ce grand parc et
guyancourt par exemple sacyr sont dans
le grand parc on l'oubli souvent alors
il reste quoi bein il reste 50 mètres de
mur sur les 43 km justement aux loges et
il reste quelques portes
alors il ya il y en a une dans le golf
national qui est en train d'être
restaurée et ça c'est sûr voisin je
crois
manille plus exactement des manies ses
manies les hameaux ces temps là c'est la
porte demeure hantée et aux loges tout
su et sait rien il ya trop quatre portes
qui suivit sur les 24 qui permettait de
rentrer dans son père tellement sur ses
portes avec l'autre chose c'est une des
photos qui vous avez le plus plu mais va
on va la voir à l'écran et j'aimerais
vous me la présentez parce que c'est une
porte de l'ancien grand parc
alors c'est une de ses porte qui avait
un passage cochet pas très grands
d'ailleurs parce qu'il fallait parfois
démonter les roues des charrettes pour
passer dessous c'est des ports ce sont
des portes qui ont été dessinés par
mansare elles étaient toutes sur le même
modèle et c'est donc déjà un premier
travail de séries si on peut dire il ya
donc trois siècles sept ans c'est 180
que ça a été construit ça devient trois
siècles et demi et ce travail a été très
bien c'est puisque il a tenu dans le
temps il n'a pas toujours été respectée
par les différents utilisateurs
actuellement sur la porte que vous voyez
là je crois eh bien il ya des tuiles
mécaniques avant c'était de l'art doit
par exemple
et qu'est-ce que vous
vous avez voulu montrer dans cette photo
justement mais justement c'est un
élément du patrimoine qui subsistent et
que doivent s'approprier un peu les
habitants et de respecter le met en
valeur j'aimerais d'ailleurs que cette
porte devienne un jour un élément
constitutif du du patrimoine connu de
tous le tout c'est peut-être une maison
du grand art qu une des maisons du grand
peuple
et ces photos là on peut les retrouver
dans votre ouvrage parce que c'est
vraiment ce qui vous inspirent ces
couvertures vous apercevez la grande
perspective de versailles qui va de la
galerie des glaces jusqu'à villepreux il
ya huit kilomètres d'un seul jet sur
lequel on essaye d'obtenir et c'est en
train de venir d'obtenir une
restauration de cette vue de manière à
ce que ce soit absolument dégagé sur les
8 km comme le voulait le nôtre et louis
xiv et il a une autre thématique qu'on
va vite se développer parce que quelque
chose avait remis l'ouvragé qui
correspond aussi surtout du système
hydraulique vraiment parlé un petit peu
c'est parce qu'ils ont ce travail le
système hydraulique qui a été conçu dans
les années 10 de 10 c 180 et même avant
est tout à fait extraordinaire il y à
peu près 220 km de rigoles
c'est à dire des grands fossés qui
collectait les eaux sur l'ensemble du
plateau de saclay et sur les étangs ce
qu'on appelle les étant supérieurs
jusqu'à pratiquement jusqu'à charte ou
en tout cas jusqu à rambouillet et cet
ensemble hydraulique alimenter les
bassins et l'ensemble des travaux qui
ont permis d'amener l'eau à versailles a
coûté les deux tiers du coût total du
domaine de versailles décor compris
ameublement compris c'est ce qui s'est
passé hors du petit parc actuel c'est
tous les travaux d'hydraulique sénateurs
aux mineurs je pense que quelques photos
en quelques fois de cheyrou ce qu'on a
plus beaucoup de temps en quelques
photos vous faisait quand même fait
découvrir énormément
je ne connaissais absolument pas
j'espère que ça a donné des idées
sorties à nos téléspectateurs qui à
travers vos photos et vos ouvrages pour
découvrir peut-être iront dans des
endroits qui ne connaissait pas je
remercie à tous les deux d'être venu en
plateau claude chose on vous retrouve
dans quelques semaines je crois donc
pour vous nous parliez du concours photo
est ce que déjà vous pouvez me rappeler
le thème de compensation à 6 et un
sourire pour 2016 puisque nous avons
terminé l'année mais 2015 quand même
avec une certaine morosité
compte tenu des évènements qui sont pas
dramatiques et son passé autour du 13 le
13 novembre
et donc c'est en attend si vous voulez
que de l'été spectateurs du téléfilm 18
nous avons à des images pleines d'espoir
pour 2016
un sourire d écouter c'est l'espoir que
qui devrait être de mise si vous voulez
pour cette année 2016 voila voila merci
à tous les deux en attendant de nous
faire rêver je vous souhaite un
excellent week-end de 7,8 week-end et un
mulet